know someone who has died from the
coronavirus
numbers just aren't good there thank you
very much david we're joined now by dr
ashish jaw he's dean of brown university
school of public health
dr jaws so much to get through if the
visor if everything goes according to
plan pfizer will start distributing the
vaccine
next week how were they able ahead how
were they able to get ahead of this
yeah good morning gail thanks for having
me on you know the uh the uk has been
doing essentially a rolling review as
your journalist mentioned and that means
they've been looking at the data all
along
uh i think our fta has been working
really fast as well and i expect to have
an authorization
next week so we're only a few days
behind them so once you get the vaccine
how soon does it become effective and
how long does it last
great questions um so you know we need
remember everybody needs to remember
that they're going to be two doses that
everybody needs to get
you may get a little bit of protection
after the first one but it's really the
second dose
that makes the big difference and we
think you have protection relatively
soon thereafter probably within a week
or two after that
uh how long it lasts we don't know my
hope is it lasts at least a year but
obviously we haven't done those longer
term studies yet so we're not sure
are you concerned about the distribution
this is a massive massive effort
never been done before what concern what
concerns you about that and how
how that's going to work
yeah you know gail this is the probably
the most complex immunization effort our
country has ever
undertaken it's very complicated because
we're going to have multiple vaccines
multiple groups that get vaccinated
tracking to make sure everybody's
getting their second dose
it's really complicated now do i think
we can pull it off i do we're gonna need
an effective federal government
we're gonna need state governments to
act effectively and then we're gonna
have to work
very closely with pharmacies and doctors
offices
uh it's gonna take a lot of work i think
we're up for the task but we gotta
you know pay close attention to all of
it is it important to remind people that
many people say think yeah we got the
vaccine we're all good
we're still not out of the woods yet
right don't people need to be reminded
about our behavior
still matters yeah gail you know we are
absolutely not out of the woods in fact
we're probably in the darkest days of
the
of the pandemic uh the next six weeks uh
while the vaccines are starting to roll
out
uh are going to be very very hard lots
of infections lots of hospitalizations
unfortunately lots of deaths
and i tell people anybody who gets
infected now and dies
is somebody who would have been who
would have gotten a vaccine two three
months from now
so we really really need to kind of
watch our behavior protect people
until we get to vaccinations okay you
know the cdc is talking about changing
the quarantine guidelines
moving it from 14 days to 7 to 10 days
depending
does that make sense to you is this a
good idea
it does and i'll tell you why most of
the evidence now
says uh that if you're gonna get
infected that you know by seven to ten
days
uh you are and so if we can shorten it
we can lower the burden of quarantining
we can make it easier for people to
quarantine
and again this is just the evidence is
changing we're learning new things about
the virus and
so i'm in general supportive